le creature dovete trovare ma attenti a
non farvi trasportare
mia madre ha
una madre
sembra il mio dormendo
[Musica]
rage grazie nero
ognuno di noi
[Musica]
siamo il libro sia portato qua in questa
campagna ma che cosa significa forse
vuol dire che la prossima creatura la
troveremo qua in questa campagna
vi ricordate che abbiamo catturato le
altre creature grazie al libro il libro
si porta dalle creature
è sentito avete sentito qualcosa dietro
forse è meglio che ci incamminiamo non
rimaniamo fermi alla porta guardato
capello
cosa dice avere inizio la divinatrice se
il tuo futuro vorrei svelare non esitare
ad entrare
divinatrice se il tuo futuro vorrei
svelare non esitare ad entrare una
creatura che il libro ci vuol far
catturare brano una creatura la
divinatrice un po strano forse lei ci
dirà dove trovare la prossima creatura
perché lei svela il futuro
che c'è profumo dalla natura
[Musica]
stato un momento questo odore di cibo ma
insomma ragazzi va detto forse la
divinatrice sta cuocendo sta cucinando
qualcosa e magari il libro ci sta
proprio conducendoli per avere un pranzo
coi fiocchi non credo al tar e al cibo
adesso dobbiamo trovare la creatura è
come se lo avete il libro sbrighiamo si
può scoprire
i miti avanti car
mi aspetto con ansia
[Risate]
guarda il cartello c'è anche qua non era
la giù il cappello forse ha messo più
cartelli perché pensava che altrimenti
ci saremmo persi e almeno sappiamo che
stiamo nella strada giusta dobbiamo
continuare andare di là abbiamo allora
giletti vi amo tantissimo insieme i miei
cari
o brutto proprio bellissimo giochino
vedrete ci divertiremo
tanto coraggio
coraggio caridi aspetto con ansia
un sapore più ma un brutto presentimento
perchè dici così senti anche il profumo
del cibo mi
permetto berenice la c'è nessuno
[Musica]
nell'inizio divinatrice e lo stesso
cartello che abbiamo trovato fuori vuol
dire che siamo nel posto giusto è qualla
divinatrice qualche libro voleva che ha
22 non cerqui
vicinanza
figurativo contro una quando c'è
qualcosa farmaci furnò le ho qui non
credo che sia una clessidra
st christie tra potrebbe avere un
qualche incantesimo sopra è meglio non
toccare niente ok vediamo solo cosa c'é
qua sotto
ok meglio non toccare niente ma cosa
dite atroci condisce all'insalata no è
una sfera di cristallo e con le sfere di
cristallo le divinatrice prevedono il
futuro credo io non ci credo a queste
cose vere mi ci sarà sicuramente lì a
preparare qualcosa da mangiare così in
più che profumo soave che c'è qua dentro
e il libro ci ha portato fin qui vuol
dire che troveremo una creatura da
qualche parte quindi guardiamoci intorno
guarda secondo me il libro già portato
qua soprattutto mi ha portato qua pronto
per farmi assaporare questi odori se ti
che profumo di pietanze ex michele
coppola ti dico bravo là dentro magari
ci fa proprio i fagioli questa giovane
sembra più forza delle pozioni quadro
che dici quasi fanno i fagioli sul fuoco
vicino donne una piatta aspetta cerca
qualcosa da mangiare il terreno
non sta indicando niente qua vuol dire
che siamo nel posto giusto però non c'è
nessuno cosa dobbiamo fare è aspettare
forse siamo nel posto giusto al momento
sbagliato cerca qualche indizio ok ok
è questa che cosa significa
guarda il sale nuova rosa dell'himalaya
una buongustaia ha fatto pure la rimasta
invece qualcosa qua ha detto
ciò che diciamo l'inizio questo e un
cappello da strega forse non lo so
oppure un cappello ne andrete da un
cammello la tuba e un cappello con voi
non credo che sarò molto felice per
inizio se ti cade con il suo cappello
addosso che è solo un cappello che cosa
vuoi che sia guarda posso fare anche il
pirata con questo il pirata vitale a
tornare in paese e temarii di borno di
capo
sono arrivato
è questo che cosa secondo te a me sembra
una canoa di quello che cos'è questo
sembra sembra una marmitta il collettore
di una marmitta non lo so che cosa ci fa
con questa una bella di una strega non
credo che siano morbida credo che sia un
qualche medico comunque un'idea nel caso
che benedice non fosse amichevole
utilizzeremo questo come arma che ne
pensi la canoa non è una canoa è una
maschera presso dobbiamo cercare con
ricette sulla creatura io tengo questa
come i romani ripeto io cerco qualcosa
per difendermi
ma che stai facendo con quelle cose
stiamo provando a suonare non lo so
magari con questa malattia la faccio la
facciamo apparirà per e nice e se poi
succede qualcosa con questa le facce
elettrica sotto le ascelle
ma così si arrabbia ancora di più è un
problema che stavo scherzando
limite le porno dove la forfora della
spalla un'idea che vedrà se per farla
comparire dove si può semplicemente
chiamarlo anzi prova a chiamarla tre
volte sono a questo strano strumento
vediamo cosa succede
berenice
belice
se fosse una cosa
che cosa c'è
minuti cari le veline timore per noi ci
accomodiamo medico accomodate e lei vero
inizio sì sono io prego accomodati tu
saresti la
prigione sono una povera vecchietta
tanto tanto sola ogni tanto mi diletto a
leggeri futuro il futuro ma c'è niente
deve aver paura private secondo voi
dovremmo fidarsi di bere inizio alla
divinatrice dovremo farci rendere il
futuro forse possiamo fare una domanda
per capirlo e cioè così signora berenice
la divinatrice ma non è che per caso ed
è che sta cucinando queste
profumatissime prelibatezze sento un
motore magnifico hop sicari sto
cucinando una bellissima pizza quattro
stagioni il viaggio e poi tre stagioni
lo sta dicendo a porta per convincerti a
farvi rete nel futuro foto la pizza è
che poi alla vita di cd rom sono solo
una povera vittima
come mai avete tanta paura di me sono
sempre tanto solo e triste finalmente i
due ospiti che possa evitare a cena io
non mi fido tanto però forse è l'unico
modo per trovare la prossima creature
libro esso ha portato qua dobbiamo per
forza ascoltare questa berenyi
ascoltiamo la darei poi che dopo sei
sono pizza tanto di guadagnato lo sa
bene sediamoci di musica e di sapere che
aveva una nomino tanto carina e mi ha
insegnato tante delle cose mi segnata
ligeri futuro a leggere il futuro
sì sì sì ma non posso fare una domanda
ma voi cosa state cercando
ormai da queste parti
non dirle niente potrebbe essere
pericoloso magari è proprio lei un acre
odore meglio non dire niente cosa
facciamo allora rinvenuti
giani si si si ci sarà anche la pizza ma
secondo me prima di lei col futuro non
arrivi da questo indizio cosa state
cercando
io sinceramente non credo che sia
possibile leggere il futuro secondo me
sei solo una ciarlatana
puoi anche non crederci a vita ma niente
può cambiare quello che è scritto nel
futuro aspetta un momento
come fai a sapere il mio nome o
[Musica]
forse l'hai fatta arrabbiare
di sicuro
non abbiate timore che niente di cui
aver paura si si io vorrei sapere che
cosa mangiano questa sera quindi signora
be nice la divinatrice mi può vendere il
futuro quello liceo il tuo futuro si
saprei anche quando morì quando maggior
hai letto della prossima fetta di pizza
o no ha impedito papardo incerto che ha
sentito quando mangerò la mia prossima
pezzo di pizza ma ha detto quando mori
si no
dobbiamo fidarci di questa parigi
andiamocene perché dai festival mela per
mangiare qualcosa magari può aiutarci a
trovare le creature prossima asi
spacchiamo la nostro vantaggio e va bene
bere inizio e dimmi pure qua dice il mio
futuro mi chiamo così
vedo vedo sì sì che questa qualcosa di
molto strano
pericoloso rigoroso che dai vostri
deviato futuro
accadrà qualcosa di molto pericoloso
prove sono ventosi via stretta
ed utile l'allievo napoli e cade un no
no se la prende potete salvare le direi
vole dovete rispettare le creature
dovete provare ma attenti a non farvi
trasformare 10 punti dovrebbe
totalizzare
sedano tradizione vivi volete tornare
e se il tempo scadere farete in una
delle mie creature di trasformerà
[Risate]
ci pensa grande sono giustamente qui
ho fatto
aspetta che che cosa ha fatto i nostri
polsi così questo sarai anche tu non lo
so fammi vedere
un marchio un segno un simbolo che cosa
vuol dire
[Risate]
ho paura che berenice la divinatrice ci
abbia lanciato una maledizione è sentito
la filastrocca chi ha detto torniamo
adesso come facciamo a trovare i dieci
punti che cosa ci aspetterà adesso ma
voi avete lasciato un mi piace mi
raccomando cliccato mi piace qua sotto e
ora andiamo a consultare il nostro libro
storie boro alla scuola di misteri per
vedere tutto abbiamo una tomba calafate
amo
ciao ragazzi ciao il libro sia portato
qua in questa foresta chissà quale sarà
la creatura che vive qua
[Musica]
siamo nel posto giusto
il primo punto
siamo nel posto giusto si quindi la
creatura di serialmente quale la foresta
qualche voce nei commenti secondo voi
che cos'è la creatura e mi raccomando
lasciate un mi piace qui sotto e ora
mandiamolo ricerca della creatura
sperando che non ci brani
tutto secco qua che cosa sono successo
forse dobbiamo cercare delle orme delle
impronte della creatura il libro indica
di là andare di qua qui porta c'è una
forma gigante ogni passo fatto dalla
creatura corrisponde a un fosso quindi
oltre a essere gigante e anche molto
pesante e in più sta andando in questa
direzione quindi potrebbe essere proprio
la direzione giusta seguiamola qui
parliamo
questo impronta proprio fresca vuol dire
che la creatura è posta d'acqua
recentemente siete teche grande e anche
lì c'era un'altra è lì lì un elefante
sembrava non mi dissi visto le orme di
qua presto di qua
guarda la porta
una casetta ma casini però l'ho dentro
la creatura vivrà la dentro una creatura
così grande e là dentro non lo so sembra
più una casetta normale magari c'è
qualcuno un contadino che vive là dentro
non lo so che sono un modo per scoprirlo
dobbiamo dare gustare lì vedere chi ci
apre sì ma teniamoci pronti con il libro
sapete che il libro è anche uno scudo
contro le creature contro le cose
paurosi ci proteggerà allora io vado a
bussare e magari non lo so chiedo se
stanno preparando qualcosa da mangiare
ora dobbiamo chiederle informazioni
sulla creatura questa è la nostra
nazione le informazioni sulla creatura è
anche la creatura dovrà mangiare appunto
magari la creatura vuole mangiare noi
non ci avevo pensato questo ai
sbrighiamoci prima che faccia buio e si
sa tutto più paura ok andiamo a chiedere
informazioni
buso io parli tu ok no guarda forse è
meglio se busso io e parli tu sai perché
magari potrebbe avermi con le mie
domande su cibo e abusato e parlo io
vabbè poi io magari fosse la seconda
domanda non ti azzardare a chiedere del
cibo mi raccomando ok ci prova non lo so
non posso promettere lo sai come sono io
no privati
[Musica]
c'è nessuno si sentono dei rumori dentro
sicuramente c'è qualcuno
senti stato un momento delle ventole
sicuramente stanno preparando da
mangiare oppure stanno mangiando
qualcuno
[Musica]
ecco vedi pd per fortuna adesso
chiediamo informazioni sulla creatura
forse non vuole proprio aprirci
stavamo in realtà cercando una creatura
lo so che è un po strano ma noi stiamo
cercando una creatura possiamo entrare
in casa e chiedervi qualche informazione
guarda mi trovate proprio una giornata
sbagliata
la casa è molto disordinata
io sono da sola e oggi non è proprio la
giornata giusta per far rientrare
ma c'è qualcuno c'è qualche creatura con
lei per caso
creatura
adesso abbiamo visto anche delle orme là
fuori giganti
abbiamo pensato che magari qualche
creatura si aggirava qui intorno alla
casa mai sentito parlare di create
intero alcuna dentro casa l'ho sentita e
dai ma giusto cinque minuti
[Musica]
per questa volta facciamo rientrare i
ragazzi
vola vola vola vola da est ria malgrado
cio gentile
sono delle domande tutti voi accomodate
mi disse che nella porta da ibra su
una casa di campagna
a questa casa
forse dovremmo andarcene ma che pochi si
chiama e una cassa di cosa mangiano con
accomodatevi accomodatevi
io provo a che cosina m
volevamo un paio di sci ci sbrighiamo
andiamo via perché buio
cala presto la notte quindi è meglio
stesso ma stringara cerca dobbiamo
sbrigarci a e così da e allora vi offro
una cosentina che vi risuona tu mi devi
promettere li devi promettere che
preparerà i ai nostri uffici che sono
venuti a farci anche domanda e che
subito andranno via micheli farai una
tisana molto decisione non tralasciate
che così è anche un po energetica perché
dovete il rito partire si
aspetti vogliono farci bere una tisana
un tenere qualcosa di strano e poi ha
detto qualcosa di quando cala la notte
sta già calando la notte e siamo in
mezzo al bosco soprattutto come faremo
ad uscirne da qui come faremo a tornare
a casa s'è fatto io cosa dobbiamo fare
secondo voi parlano tutti perché si
sanno dobbiamo assolutamente sapere se
c'è una creatura qua quindi l'unico modo
per farsi dare le informazioni credo che
sia bene questa tipa da per ci dobbiamo
sprecare dobbiamo assolutamente
chiedergli della creatura 20 punti e
andare via velocemente altrimenti se non
prendiamo tutti e dieci punti berenice
si trasformerà in una creatura
abbiamo pochi minuti di tempo per
rispondere alle vostre domande poi li
dobbiamo mandare via cala presso la
notte si va benissimo benissimo perché
facciamo tutte le domande che creatura
34 che abbiamo vinto devi programmare
creatura quale creature avete visto
che non ne avete visto
ma che degli auguri se si parlava di
fronte rob huff ha portato
il bue di dj francesco che viene ogni
tanto non lasciamo io non ho pure oppure
oppure qua vicino c'è una casa dove ci
sono tanti bambini che avevano giocare
ogni tanto fanno i dispetti e quindi
creano delle enormi
poi tu esci loro intento e quello che
noi siamo la quale si fa vendiamo è però
ormai siamo abituati
e allora se non c'è nessuna creatura
quando ce ne andiamo via andiamo via
togliamo il disturbo non ci dite niente
della creatura allora noi ce ne andiamo
[Musica]
te lo dicono come dopo giorno quando
vale andare via prima tenta di dire
quando siamo un po che beviamo una
positiva insieme siete venuti qua non
quelli infuso che preparato la settimana
scorsa che è conservato 9 no
no assolutamente
sei sicuro solo dei ricercatori questi
come me è capito a colori ci credo che
l'unica soluzione sia interrelati state
altrimenti non ti dirò mai dove la
creatura magari un richiamo così per ora
prima che faccia poi mi servono delle
foglioline di più pisa che sono giù in
fondo al viale a destra il prestigio
estivo che si dice
prenditi cesti netto papa lo devi
promettere che dopo lo prometti melo che
non che non gli dai quell infuso lì che
abbiamo messo via papa guardami negli
occhi e prometti melo
pero provento non ti preoccupare
va bene mi ha convinto per di cestinato
vai è stata un pochettino di quei fiori
di faber ad ora per i cesti netto 15 so
niente
brava mi raccomando 23 mazzetti nino che
va bene fare torno presto ciao
ma una nota ci sono anche i biscotti sia
sì anche i biscottini
biscotti che si estenderà anche non vedo
l'ora di assaggiare incappati nei
biscotti tardi
[Musica]
e perché facciamo non messaggiamo in
visione liberista siamo qui e ti non ci
dovremmo binari di questo signor lino
perché ora qualcosa di strano non veneti
ma supergentile ci prepara ladisa ma ci
offre pure i biscotti e tutto fatto in
casa tra l'altro che ci sia d'italia ma
cercare la creatura sia segno non bere
né mangiare niente io non ho mai ragione
la creatura da cerchiamo perugia che
siamo qua usiamo uniamo l'utile al
dilettevole
biscotti latisana le domande sulla
creatura è perfetto secondo voi cosa
dovremmo fare dovremmo bere latisana del
signor lino oppure dovremmo scappare da
qua io non ho dubbi su questo
sicuramente dovrà bere e mangiare prima
di andare alla ricerca prima si mangia
si beve
e va bene speriamo almeno che dopo ci
dia una risposta sulla creatura
[Musica]
eccoci qua
raffreddato
un'allergia a mano alla che pativano sì
sto cercando con le erbe di di curarmi
la destra ti porta boost biscotti i
costi grazie
al 20 che invece si sta facendo è sì un
pochettino
svitato ma adesso consentiva non potete
biscottini in ultim'ora che stia
nascondendo qualcosa invece che cosa
stanno ascoltando sto guardando anche
quella di sale così tra
branzi meno molto gentile questa
allergia che mi prende e sempre ma
stoffa ti sto cercando una soluzione è
un vocalizzo che mi viene strano
mal di gola è ceo particolare viene
fuori
e biscotti quale se prendo un
medico e gentile giornata delle sponde e
questo è buonissimo con bobby moore
sto sentendo qualcosa ecco tutto bene
tutto bene se mi prende sempre un po
così ma ho trovato quasi video
e video o particolare purissima e non vi
accomodate comodato come camilo si state
più
canali avviciniamo le cose in comune
temi del divano o
sa che avevi ragione impossibilitato
cerchiamo di finire velocemente questa
titola così potrà darsi le informazioni
sulla creatura
[Musica]
scusatemi temi di sbrigarmi
4 biscottino di andrebbe e di biscottino
soldi o feb
un po strana sarei anch'io un pochettino
accomodiamoci ripassiamo fatto ma datevi
tranquilli effetti
quale versi strano questo posto anzi è
molto rilassante mi saluti suggere
pisolino
catene cassini è la trascinano si ok
dovete riposarsi di scottie
discorso io li tengo intendo hahnemann
giornale sei tu
apprezzo molto
[Musica]
vediamo io sapevo
stiamo andando di qua o l'unico e
toccare sono
buono
ti prego non passa in fretta io le notti
di luna piena le odio come supporto
tutte
questi romani
ciao maria ciao vi siete addormentati
strano che ci siamo addormentati
no no non è strano el'atmosfera il posto
avete fatto una camminata scarante vi
siete stancati a camminare aspetta un
attimo il vino dove è il mio papà che si
e trasformarsi e trasformato in un dio
si si è andata a dormire perché era
molto molto molto molto stanco mi ha
detto di salutarvi e mi ha detto di
accompagnarvi alla porta
te lo avevo detto che avevo qualcosa di
strano quel signore a parte lui firmato
cosa sono queste no è che la casa è un
buffet che quindi scricchiola stata di
legno ma vengono da lì andiamo là per un
fatto di cronaca sono scrivo così si
lasciano però c'è il nostro cagnolino
che fa che quando vivace soprattutto la
notte qui in bagno non capisco è un
cagnolino un po grande però è molto
vivace quindi lo crede essere questa la
creatura che stiamo cercando un
cagnolino che in realtà è
mai visto lupo mannaro in vita mia mai
mai mai ve lo posso giurare ragazzi non
ho mai dette un lupo mannaro
io ho solo detto lupo infatti ci ha
detto il comando nascondendo qualcosa
dentro no no non siamo da meno
non potete aprire questa porta perché
non possiamo aprire questa porta perché
non si può perché non si può aprire
non vi posso fare a fare
guardare
più mosso a mosso
noi non lo sapevo che non volevo farvi
entrare adesso adesso ormai è troppo
tardi
mio padre mi ha morso è un lupo mannaro
sì ormai lo sapete diamo orso inutile
che conte che io continuo a tenere il
segreto
è importante chi viene morso da un lupo
mannaro e condannato a divenire un lupo
mannaro a sua volta lo sapevo e adesso
chi già c'è già sento che mi sta venendo
qualcosa abbraccio vi sto trasformando
guarda quanto ho problemi con tale di
dianesi a di canale via non possiamo
dire di qua dentro
no mai
assolutamente mandato via po mordere
anche noi siamo in pericolo
ma io non voglio mandarlo vergogna
chiamavano via fu morderci così perfetta
sicuro nel bosco voglio che sia da sono
al buio di nota è un lupo mannaro cosa
vuoi che succeda
per me vitale
si
no
aspetta
funzionato un'idea ferma lì
speriamo che non torni più per tutta la
notte adesso
bellezza di vista qualcuno sta mostrando
la porta
sembra abitare la voce ma non so se
ancora trasformato il lupo mannaro posso
aprire quel che vale è la prima alla
porta magari sito sei più esperta in
fatto di lupo mannaro che mi portò è
meglio che aprì tu
mi sento che siete là dentro aprire temi
[Musica]
dei normali
sì mi ricordo che è sparito non c'è più
il morso verrà se ritornato compilazione
di normale sì ma io mi ricordo che il
lungo ieri mi aveva mosso certo se lo
ricordiamo benissimo salim prima di
aprirla mortarino noi non abbiamo la
porta e pericoloso no state calmi
tranquilli non c'è bisogno di
spaventarsi né di agitarsi adesso è
tutto a posto dunque
no non avere paura di tranquillo lui
comunque sta ancora dormendo ancora
nella stanza dove la ieri notte quindi è
tutto normale tutto regolare non
spaventatevi non dovete avere paura è
tutto normale sito regolare lino mio
papà è ancora chiuso nella sua stanza ma
non dovete avere paura c'è qualcosa che
non cosa forse questo bisogno di alcune
spiegazioni
forse preferireste sedervi così vi
racconto un po quello che è successo a
te quello che è successo a mio papà e
magari capirete meglio anche un po la
storia il libro ci ha portato qua per
collezionare i punti per la creatura
esistiamo ritrovati con began è
trasformato il lupo mannaro e non
abbiamo ancora preso i ponti una volta
presi punti potremmo anche andarsene ma
almeno sentiamo cosa da raccontarci
magari racconta qualcosa che riuscirà a
darci punti ricordiamoci anche che c'è
rimasto pochissimo tempo dobbiamo
sbrigarci sì adesso sentiamo questa
dispensa che innanzi tutto com'è
possibile che tuo padre che a quanto ho
capito è ancora chiusa la dentro è un
lupo mannaro
anzi
ho paura
quindi meglio secondo un occhio guardo
di qua paura che esca da un momento
all'altro
sto facendo buongiorno
è uscito
[Applauso]
[Musica]
male
non
papa ieri notte ai moser vitale
mi dispiace
vi spiego tutto no no trovare i nostri
clienti
almeno proviamo utilizzare il libro
contro di un ufficio bono si librano
piedi lavoro non fare soldi siano sulla
secondo il genere il libro crea un video
contro le creature cattive che
massacrato da zero ci beviamo un
tema
assolutamente non vuoi più niente ma vi
ricordate ieri sognato di avere quel
tratto una cucina niente incantare la
scarpa e poi dopo ci siamo addormentati
mi ha pure forze e anzi noi ce ne
andiamo ottenuto niente
è importante che io ho visto di tutto
venite qua vi devo spiegare tutto vi
devo spiegare tutto vi giuro che non
morde rowe più nessuno vince la luce è
una cosa che succede solo in una piena
di notte forse sta dicendo la verità mi
si trasforma tutto da madri notati sera
la luna piena e ora è tornato umano ed è
buono quindi noi dobbiamo avere i famosi
disturbo ma nero per prendere i punti
dobbiamo per forza sfruttarlo non so se
crederci o no però è la nostra unica
possibilità per conoscere più
informazioni ma mi vedete sono un uomo
normale sono normalissime ma
effettivamente è vero sembra un uomo
normale adesso sembra completamente
diverso da com'era ieri è solamente un
incantesimo accomodatevi il papa non si
ricorda quello che è successo ieri notte
e quindi vogliamo spiegarvi cosa è
successo tanto tempo fa e cosa è
successo stanotte per questo che neanche
tu vitale che ricordi quello che è
successo ok il signor lino ci sediamo è
però sbrigatevi abbiamo bisogno di
sapere le informazioni il prima
possibile anche perché c'erano
3 si
cela divinatrice papà mi ha fatto
l'incantesimo non abbiamo molto tempo io
sto cercando la formula per rompere
questo incantesimo
aspettate privi di papà gian maria conto
cosa succederà dunque a punti ok adesso
vi racconto dall'inizio come sono andate
le cose mio padre è stato maledetto da
berenice la divinatrice non so se voi
magari la conoscete l'avete già sentita
nominare diciamo che l'abbiamo già
incontrata e ci ha lasciato un segno mio
padre come voi aveva delle sfide da
affrontare peccato che non è riuscito a
risolverle tutte e quindi beni ce l'ha
ma ne ha detto e lo ha fatto diventare
una delle sue creature è per questo che
ogni luna piena si trasforma proprio
mancino che stiamo cercando io sto
facendo solo qua per fare le ricerche
però ci manca una camera mentre ci manca
qualcosa sono le radici di barzana e
fiorellini di elicriso
il bullo che berlino 1 mortellaro bus
crocus
quindi non avete ancora trovato
l'antidoto che cosa vi manca esattamente
c'è sempre qualcosa che manca siamo
vicini alla formula lo manca forse un
ingrediente fondamentale che non
riusciva a capire qual è e non lo
troviamo quando troveremo l'ingrediente
mio papà non si trasformerà mai più e
abbiamo per sempre risolto non diventerà
mai più un lupo mannaro e potremmo
essere felici per sempre
noi abbiamo il libro abbiamo il nostro
libro storie paurose un libro che ha dei
poteri magari se andrebbe aiutarvi a
trovare questo antidoto questo
ingrediente o un possiamo la nota che
manca magari possiamo capire qual è
l'ingrediente che manca ma quindi voi
avete delle pozioni che avete già fatto
degli antidoti avete qualcosa si sia
fissato
dall emozione tasti co dai fare ce la
facciamo insieme
portiamo una v proveniamo che cosa c'è
scritto magari anche la scheda creatura
vediamo la scheda creatura oppure prima
propria ma le loro posizioni e poi
vediamo la scheda creatura ma ottima
idea perché queste sono le pozioni gli
asili questi sono tutte le ricerche le
mie ricerche di anni che ho fatto
bisogna provarle vitale si ti devi
fidare di me
qualche cosa c'è qualche effetto
particolare ma poi non è molto
importante però dobbiamo dobbiamo
trovare insieme questa questa soluzione
per la nostra salvezza ha detto qualche
effetto particolare
cosa potrebbe succedere
non lo so se ho detto che legge
approvate che cosa vuoi che succeda beh
dobbiamo trovare una soluzione perchè tu
sei stato morso è lui a questo
incantesimo quindi deve trovarli
comunque per l'opera ok magari e melissa
si allonta di gruppo è forse la cosa
giusta si proviamoli
wow che colore stupendo e meglio è alice
della siberia amici della siberia ma non
è che mi sentivo male dopo no allora le
possiamo provare adesso che la nostra si
esprime bene
ma
mi fido 20 ott i siti ma
è solo gli effetti che non ci
aspettavamo o no non mi dire che vitale
non tornerò mai normale parlerò sempre
così
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
volete a mischiare le funzioni tra di
loro mi è rimasto un po di casa tocca
con mano per la 33 non penso che sara
posto guardare sicuro se ce la facciamo
a 331 ho paura di fare l'uomo dopo
questa io non l'ho provata ok non l'ha
mai provata ok allora forse meglio
allontanarsi uno che ti non si metterà
in luce la goccia
ho
avuto un po di
televisore
melissano senti le pozioni di tuo papà
non hanno funzionato che io se cerchiamo
una soluzione del libro che hai basta
con le funzioni anche io però gente di
berle ok avete fatto vi troppi disastri
oggi ma con sastre che ci siamo
divertiti un sacco
ecco la spina creatura allora vediamo
che cosa dice la ferocia di un
licantropo e spaventosa e l'unico modo
per contrastare un suo attacco e
affidarsi alle armi d'argento solo
questo metallo infatti può stordire la
creatura e bloccarne i poteri ma queste
sono tutte informazioni che noi già
sappiamo che cosa potrebbe essersi b
lista tu conosci benissimo i lupi
mannari family legge un attimo bloccare
i poteri l'argento può bloccare i poteri
della creatura avete mai provato ad
irritare l'argento nella tre mozioni no
non abbiamo mai usato l'argento lo
possiamo trovare un ingrediente finanza
dobbiamo cercare james johnson ospiti
alluvione la nonna dove software si
guarda da quel pranzo
questo
oriente qui ci sono basta ma una latta
di alluminio non è argento questo
d'argento questo è velista il progetto
questo questo metallo non è argento o
forse non c'è niente d'argento qua
questo forse questo ci per cento sembra
argento a me sembra alluminio sai
confronto nel cassetto delle posate si
dovrebbero essere forse qua
no non ce li teniamo qui hanno stretto
un momento che cosa hai provato velista
questa collana in argento e potrebbe
essere d'argento di vista quando
profumo proviamo a emergere la
nell'ultimo antidoto che abbiamo fatto
papa l'ultimo che sembrava funzionare
quasi perfettamente quello che va bene
la macchina ma basterà immergerla si è
altro penso di sì ok diciamo sì certo
proviamo speriamo che funzioni
forse conviene che l'antidoto lo beviamo
fuori per evitare esplosioni o sorprese
si vestì collaterali
in bocca al lupo
scusa hai ragione regione una forma
fortuna una buona fortuna
allora come vi sentite tutto bene o se
siete tu sì
[Musica]
adesso siete liberi anche voi potete
proseguire il vostro viaggio vivo
continua nella nostra missione dobbiamo
prendere tutti e dieci punti altrimenti
saprebbe benissimo bene inizio ci
trasformerà in una delle sue creature
andate a quella fortuna che lascia lo
staff in giudizio i ragazzi grazie
melissa ciao ciao milan capolista
ora il libro dove ci porterà lo
scopriremo nei prossimi episodi lasciato
il mi piace cosa volete vedere il
continuo e voi ce l'avete il libro
pronti già dalla prossima avventura di
obi
siamo dove siamo finiti questa volta
il libro ci ha portato in un nuovo luogo
troveremo un'altra creatura qua vi
ricordate ma se successo all'ultimo voto
se non l'avete visto andate poi a
vederlo e lasciate un mi piace mi
raccomando per portarci fortuna in
questa nuova avventura e nuova creatura
grazie mille tantissimi di voi hanno già
preso attori paura non capiamo la di
mente rivista piacendo tantissimo grazie
mille e ora pronti andiamo a scoprire la
prossima creatura
sembra che il libro indyk iniqua
facciamo di portare
guarda c'è una casa chiusa creatura sarà
dentro quella casa in questo caso la
casa caro toccata e sembra una casa
normale non come quella del lupo mannaro
vi ricordate eh sì
proviamo a buttare vediamo chi ci vive
dentro mangia
[Applauso]
ma non si vede niente
che strano
da questa finestra non si vede niente
anzi sembra proprio che sia stata
oscurata
guardate va beh vediamo se c'è un'altra
finestra c'è un altro figlio di dio
ma anche questa finestra e oscura si è
un po strano c'è una pianta e poi è
oscurata almeno c'è una pianta già
sappiamo che forse qualcuno ci vive
dentro no speriamo che non ci viva la
creatura dentro lo scopriremo presto
proviamo gustare
vediamo presto ecco vorrei
quadra in questa strana casa porta la
differenza prima latte intero non era
queste sono bianchi perché forse un
indizio proviamo a bussare magari si
apre qualcuno e possiamo fare queste
domande chiederli sale tengo perché le
tende sono bianchi invece che bere
chiedere della creatura per una volta
che mi ricordo quello che devo fare ben
presto gustiamo secondo voi che creatura
troveremo fa dentro pronti 3 boscoscuro
notte nessuno qui
vedete sono bianchi e quindi ho pensato
che magari questo posto giusto visto che
rivale dente sono nere
sembra una ragazza
salve buongiorno scusate il disturbo
volevamo chiedere delle informazioni
prossimo delle creature ad esempio
possiamo
ancora molto
come molto presto sono le cinque di
pomeriggio presto in che senso
era un po pallida però non era una
creatura una ragazza normale ce li
possiamo stare tranquilli è solo che non
è molto ospitale questa ragazza
effettivamente proviamo a ributtarsi non
rispondi più tagliandata guarda sembra
abbia lasciato la porta un po aperta ai
possiamo dare una sbirciatina per vedere
se c'è una creatura e tirava
controlliamo se c'è la creatura diciamo
sbirciamo solo ma cerchiamo di non farci
scoprire s piano piano che
[Musica]
qualcosa no ma il libro mi sta portando
qua quindi credo che stiamo nel posto
giusto
[Musica]
nel posto giusto ma abbiamo preso il
primo punto
[Musica]
arredamento particolare le maschere
ma c'è qualcuno che
dovremmo metterci accertare alla
creatura non conoscere chi abita in
questa casa concordo psi
[Musica]
figlio voleva rifare la porta era aperta
quindi ci siamo permessi di rientri
nelle strade
noi volevamo solo fare due domande non
ci tratteniamo
ok volevamo gestire l'informazione sulla
creatura ma se proprio cd è anche mura
delle creazioni
forse è meglio non dirle niente
proviamo a conoscere la famiglia ea
vedere la casa e vediamo cosa succede
mio padre
mia madre ha
una madre
sembra il mio dormendo
non è così mi chiedevo
perché questo per me il napoli
non riesce a suonare
[Musica]
molto piacere signora verucchio a sirio
stiamo parlando di passaggio grazie
conosciamo letto con piacere anche per
lei
sull amati segnata nostra ancora
dormendo
per piacere
sveglia una dormendo ancora non lo so mi
sta guardando mi stai perdendo formale
grazie per la vostra ospitalità o credo
che a breve andremo via penso di sì
e qui c'è mio padre a padre
la famiglia quindi
elogiata
da vale il padre stava dormendo sulla
sedia che ogni tanto mi addormento sulla
sedia ma di certo no di quella posizione
nessun membro di questa famiglia mi
sembra normale forse meglio stazioni
andiamo via subito
torniamo di
giovani
[Musica]
avete conosciuto lì non c'è anche un
altro membro della famiglia e fortuna
questo sarà sicuramente più normale
ospiti madre vissuti nuovo già bigottoni
un altro aspetto che succede madre mi
scusi ma cosa sta succedendo proviamo a
mappare se facciamo proprio vicino alla
porta
ci accomodiamo
accendendo il fuoco
ho detto la cena la cera o ha detto cena
c'erano no no no no non importa lo
genera adesso non mi rifaccio sono
strani giochiamo perchè non importa
invece ma che vuoi che sia una cena in
fondo non ha mai ucciso nessuno no certo
sarete affamati sicura
facciamo così rimaniamo ce ne sono se
poi ci date le informazioni sulla
creatura che stiamo cercando che insieme
giusto così possiamo
campionatura
accomodiamo ci accomodiamo
praticamente
certo sul controverso re io questo che
che cos'è casa al
ddl un progetto il cadere il 1800 detto
ok puzza di ferro zolfo ottimo
torniamo al è morto questo grazie stiamo
bene così a noi interessa solo sapere le
informazioni se una creatura ma anche
l'ho già
ricordati che dobbiamo prendere tutti i
ponti altrimenti verranno trasformati
delle venature non ha detto sì ma
dobbiamo anche mangiare
prendiamo anche le informazioni ma
mangiavo ricordiamoci di mangiare
sapete cosa faccio preparare la
cina e russia
roma 20 che visto che stiamo aspettando
che vostra madre prepara la cena poche
mani terra famiglie domanda sulla
creatura adesso
certo allora semplicemente fratello
abbiamo spiegarvi tutta la storia non
dobbiamo assolutamente trovare
una creatura
perché messo su questo punto così strano
ci stanno guardando in modo così strano
vabbè comunque dobbiamo trovare questa
creatura altrimenti se non prendiamo
tutti i punti beh abbiamo una
maledizione quindi se non prendiamo
tutti i punti
diventeremo noi una creato grossi noi
dobbiamo assolutamente trovarla e
confezionare i punti nel libro che pure
che ricordi forse quelle enormi falle
minuti tre eletti tre
mogli ma in realtà parlavamo di creature
sovrannaturali che sotto ci sono
creature soprannaturali le rose
porta meglio di nuovo l'ultima volta il
6 guardatelo trasformate non lo può
mannaro sono beni soprattutto
di
mamma mia che schifo non mi ricordo
nemmeno sono mangiato quando quella
volta che sono stato trasformarono noi
odiamo i lupi mannari
si prendano anche il nostro cibo si
presentano berlusca gli ospiti sono
affamati
ci siamo massignano
scusate
ma io non mi sono
presentato
mi sembrate intimo i
finiani
[Risate]
ma io sono con te
filiberto cosa stavate cercando e allora
praticamente è una lunga storia comunque
noi stiamo cercando una creatura
sovrannaturale perché lì ma ho già detto
che la creatura equa quindi di un pò
strano che voi non avete mai visto
nessuna creatura qua fuori in giardino
in casa non lo so perché non vi siete
mai accorti di niente non so qui in casa
o fuori in giardino ma memore
particolari avete mai visto
il conte filiberto si è addormentato
signor poco siete mercato
scusate che
si preoccupi fosse camera fini si dove
poté motore queste creature oppure
come creature ecco come creature come
soprattutto cali molto grandi
soprannaturale siamo noi
mio padre voleva dire siamo
nobili
ma da dove usciva quella
cosa ha detto che porta la dentiera
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma è insomma possibile che non avete mai
sentito un rumore
[Applauso]
si possono fare
[Musica]
anche questo voi avete visto
se stessi temi dalla fine è
oscurato anche quelle non si può neanche
aprire
possibile perché non c'è niente
la cena è quasi pronta tutti a tavolino
accomodato miacard
perché è pronto
visto pero mi metto qui
ma
dove sono i piatti le portate mangiavo
con le mani madre
iniziamo dagli ospiti grazie
vedrete che l'impianto
non vedo l'ora o una fame io
ci
sarà il primo ad essere serenità che
bello che bello vedere
un fazzoletto che volevo fare qualcosa
per problemi per non sporcare nuova band
la fame che però si mangia mangia ci
voleva un lenzuolo
si mangia tanto qui ma se ci sono ancora
i piatti senza troppo che si mangia
questo vino sembra del 1800
deve essere un vino un prodotto
finito che bella casa che avrete si vede
che siete proprio dei
normanni a questa carta da quanto tempo
abitate fisse
probabilmente
c5
cinque giorni fa
vi ho già detto che porta lamenti erano
500 armi sono tanti infatti agito
500 da poco
siete quelli appena arrivati freschi
freschi pronti ma
venite venite dalla transilvania
l'antico siamo venuti con quelle grandi
navi abbiamo attraversato l'oceano
ma invece voi ragazzi che fate andate a
scuola è certo io sono già il quinto
diploma al quinto diploma
5 10 crisi siete di 25 anni
ma il nome nuovo
è
convinto il mio fratellino
e viviamo noi ti prende il fumo è anche
a volte due diplomi all'anno
se un diploma all'anno 5 anni 5 di
gloria che berlusconi
comi caro arrivo
ho impiegato un po di tempo ma vi
assicuro che il risultato
fare sognare
finalmente credereste sarà una vera
sorpresa
che bello non vedo l'ora
signora maruska psi mancano i piatti
servono i piatti per questa pietanza non
serve è qualcosa di originale ma
qualcosa di mai visto
forse da dove vengono loro è usanza non
usare i piatti mi piace mi piace molto
forse perché fa missy ma qualcosa che
non sa di tiro mai assaggiato
[Musica]
e successo mettono un po strano
il fratellino ma me ne sono accorto ci
aveva sorpreso il collo prima
beh equilibrio
nella lontana tradizione chi deve aprire
più grosso di
ospite
[Musica]
succede ma
se succede
[Musica]
vabbè io mo sono si raffredda
nella scena
[Musica]
chiudere
sì sono utili
[Musica]
ma cosa facciamo adesso
c'è stato un equivoco
la cena si cesoia doverla preparare
tradizione di
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quindi non volevano che noi cucina
assimo per loro quindi
tempo tra i pro grande chef che ne
pensate
facciamo un agevole veloci che ne
pensate ma gli oli tipologie
maria
mi son caduti e indie dallo schifo
nonno di mangiare cibi che titolo the
late devo i presto vediamo la scheda
creatura sui vampiri troviamo un piccolo
il bambino il bambino è una creatura
sovrannaturale molto antico
particolarmente diffusa nell'europa
dell'est si nutre del fango degli esseri
umani e può trasformare le proprie
vittime
i nuovi vampiri mordendoli sul collo è
uno che come volevano trasformati i
nuovi bambini ecco perché il figlio mi
stavo sempre attaccato il congresso da
volevamo torme riconoscere questa
creatura può essere difficoltoso
ecco perché ci sembravano solo un po
strani all'inizio non avevano neanche i
denti perché all'apparenza è simile a un
essere umano a parte i seguenti tratti
che tradiscono la sua vera natura
mostruosa ha la pelle molto chiara erano
pallidi e non può esporsi alla luce
diretta del sole che lo ridurrebbe in
cenere
quindi forse questo può aiutarci ma
vediamo continua a leggere a canini
molto lumi per succhiare sangue non si
ripete negli specchi non invecchia
riposa solo nella propria bara e
sensibile alle luci troppo forti e non
sopporta l'odore dell'olio
ecco perché hanno reagito così quando
gli ho detto dellai olio magari facciamo
un arrabbiata
noi siamo questi ci
sono il monoriti ci
stiamo ho un'idea se aspettiamo che
sorga il sole perché se loro fanno
dormire quando fa quando c'è luce è vero
all'alba probabilmente ok aspettiamo che
non vadano a dormire qui siamo di qua e
apre una porta e scappiamo scappiamo si
pesca non resisto ho bisogno di bere
sì sì per festeggiare sono i chiusi in
più per se gli eventi la notte
lì a sé per ma abbiamo tutto il
l'importante adesso è che non ci
addormentiamo perché ho paura che se ci
addormentiamo loro ci vengano a prendere
un buon giorno dobbiamo ri per vie
accertare che stiamo al bacco di loro
dormiranno e noi potremmo provare sono
d'accordo con te non ci addormentiamo no
ma teniamoci svegli ok
hai detto ma ulteriori belli perché
stavo dormendo bene possiamo andare a
dormire così posso mettere i miei canini
sotto il cuscino e durante il giorno il
pipistrello dei ceri me li porterò via
sta per sorgere il sole
io sonno
sì sì è tempo di andare a dormire
dobbiamo resistere
tanto dalla nostra cosa non si può
fuggire sono in trappola si sono i boia
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi è l'alba
stanno correndo
non lo so spero di sì i bambini dormono
di giorno quindi siccome lampo ha
probabilmente sono già andati a dormire
ora possiamo provare a scappare si
sentono dei rumori stiamo attenti non
facciamoci scoprire lasciate un mi piace
per portarci fortuna
sì
ok visto che stanno dormendo
proviamo a scappare
[Musica]
ma come facciamo adesso ma non ne
abbiamo il libro come scudo aspetta
aspetta un attimo magari hanno nascosto
la chiave oppure ce l'hanno loro tipo
appesa al collo oppure al braccio o
nelle tasche dobbiamo dobbiamo
controllarle magari ce l'hanno loro ok
cerchiamo la chiave si è vero
[Applauso]
no no non è sbagliata ok passiamo al tar
si sta tornando con un pieno sauro
quello deve essere l'orsacchiotto degli
i vampiri
tappeti kant
per fortuna dorme profondamente
dopo questa una chiave neanche qua
controlliamo sa il padre alla chiave
addosso
la chiave di
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa mattina gamba
grazie pirone salvato la piuma testa
arrivato a roma aveva la chiave addosso
no ho controllato non aveva nulla ok
controlliamo al padre per l'ultimo
rimasto
no
[Musica]
non esiste una chiara
mafiosa fiabe ci hanno chiusi a chiave
qua dentro non potevo neanche scappare
non sappiamo dove la chiave come
possiamo fare come rivedere la scheda
creatura le chiavi oppure le chiavi non
ce l'avevano addosso magari con un
telecomando aprono le porte alle
finestre col telecomando può essere i
compiti del 1800 non avevano il
telecomando e sensibile rossi
non può esporsi alla luce diretta del
sole la luce diretta del sole all idea
siccome non riusciamo a scappare perché
siamo chiusi dentro possiamo aprire
finestre ed è scritto che loro si
riducono il genere alla luce diretta del
sole quindi se noi avremo le finestre
che loro hanno oscurato il rosito il
solo di colpiranno e loro si
trasformeranno in genere aspetta però è
ancora l'alba non lo so appena andati a
dormire dobbiamo aspettare che il sole
sia più alto cambia più luce ok
aspettiamo
vediamo il nostro piano erano mezzi
addormentati aspettiamo che il sole sia
bello alto poi riusciamo
apriamo le finestre però non
addormentiamo c no no no no la dormitio
così quando vediamo se troppo pericoloso
tra siamo svegli programmi volti
stacchini al 1 o chiusi
non mesi e mi e ci addormentiamo ormai
siamo arrivati qui mancano poche ore
al mattino ci ha messo fine giornata
guarda senza la luce del sole
dobbiamo uscire che lo piano facciamo se
leggessi sugli animi bambini e apriamo
le finestre per far entrare la luce del
sole per l'ingegneria giusto giusto
giusto
tempo ti ricordi cosa devo pre di tela
fino a truccarsi dobbiamo prendere 10
punti altrimenti ci trasformeremo in
creature dobbiamo fare di altri miti
svegliamo le creature immobili c'è più
tempo per fare il piano non abbiamo più
tempo capisci meno lei pensa unisce il
tempo verranno trasformati in creature
al servizio di bere dice per sempre e
grossi ceri bambini e prima possibile sì
c'è più tempo mangiamo piano abbiamo ad
aprire le finestre
da quella finestra iniziamo siamo noi
proviamo ad aprire quella finestra per
entrare la luce e poi non ci mette c'è
anche quella alta la stessa iniziamo con
quel insieme più vicina
oggi un incantesimo e la terra promosso
capitano il libro
[Musica]
non
solo con il libro
sta succedendo
[Musica]
dobbiamo aprire
la
finestra
che cosa è successo
una barriera si
aspetta proviamo con il libro prof
senso ha preso anche l'altra per noi
sarebbe la fine
[Applauso]
[Musica]
li abbiamo presi si sono comparsi quale
libro sono i pipistrelli sono quindi
punti ma ora ha detto scappiamo presto
andiamo via dalla casa mi va benissimo
ed ora sappiamo
abbiamo subito la maledizione di
berenice si
e poi avete lasciato mi piace e avete
già storie paura a grappolo di misteri
se non ce l'avete ancora andate a
prenderlo mi raccomando lasciate un mi
piace posto so se volete che la nostra
avventura contini lui e altre prove si
aspetteranno proseguiamo e lo scopriremo
assieme
e di vinto però so io
ma mi sono anche divertita ragazzi
siete convinti che il gioco finisca qui
poveri illusi ma non avete capito chi
sono io
tutti
[Musica]